[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
alles muss größer schneller besser
werden die gesellschaft ist im wahn des
wachstums erliegen der gedanke mit etwas
aufzuhören gehört nicht dazu so aufhören
jetzt etwas negatives in diesem kult ur
modell es ist ja so was wie eine
niederlage
doch es gibt momente da muss man
innehalten weil die welt und auch das
leben endlich sind
natürlich
[Musik]
sogar noch ein hit
kulturplatz über die kunst aufzuhören
[Musik]
wir kommen auf dem kulturplatz ja aller
anfang ist schwer so sagt es der
volksmund doch in tat und wahrheit ist
das doch so dass das aufhören unendlich
viel schwieriger ist man ist denn der
richtige moment sich etwa in würde zu
trennen zurückzutreten oder auch um zu
sterben darüber spreche ich gleich mit
dem schweizer fotografen reto camenisch
sein werk ist hier an den bieler
fototage zu sehen etwa dieses große
bildes entstand nach seiner
krebsdiagnose die sein ganzes leben
komplett auf den kopf stellte weshalb
aufführen wollte mit allem es kam anders
[Musik]
reto camenisch wieso hat sie wählen
denn fotografiert wenn jetzt im
ausland stark beteiligt
der traum newsletter mm müsse daraus
sind immer weniger ranicki lokal zudem
moniert ist zeigt hat die musik position
beziehen das gespräch mit mir suchen
also
die eigene endlichkeit so enorm bewusst
wird dass man damit umgeht unbedingt das
hat natürlich immer druck dass der
moment da fahre ich
und rechnete mit oder hofft dass er
vielleicht sogar noch gewitter möglich
aus der affäre und mit der ästhetik
mutig wie nichts wie vor ist das
natürlich verschiedene sachau die die
parallele
danke fürs erste reto camenisch der
soziologe harald welzer behauptet in
unserer kultur falles uns ganz besonders
schwer mit dem aufhören alles müsse
immer weitergehen größer und noch besser
werden sein buch zum thema trägt den
titel nachruf auf mich selbst und es ist
sein letztes er sagt
harald welzer ein soziologe ein zukunfts
denker der in den medien gerne auskunft
gibt
er spricht über nachhaltigkeit über
unsere gesellschaft und das unaufhörlich
im april 2020 kam er seinem tod sehr
nahe
kurz nach einem interview erlitt er
einen herzinfarkt den er durch einen
glücksfall fast unversehrt überlebt hat
ein schock der den ausschlag gab ein
buch zu schreiben eine beschäftigung mit
dem aufhören
ich wollte ursprünglich ein buch darüber
schreiben dass eine sozial ökologische
transformation nicht möglich ist wenn
man nicht aufhört sondern immer nur
optimiert das war der gedanke den ich
vorher schon hatte dann kam dieses
lebensbedrohliche ereignis dazu nach
diesem ereignis wird ihm noch klarer
dass wir in einer diktatur der gegenwart
leben ohne verhältnis zum tod und das
ist der grund dass uns aufhören so
schwer fällt denn die moderne
gesellschaft hat ein dogma alles soll
immer weitergehen oder besser noch eine
steigerung zum vorherigen sein immer
mehr immer besser wachstums kapitalismus
[Musik]
das präferiert dass man dass man
weitermacht ist es aufhören völlig
unverständlich so aufhören jetzt etwas
negatives in diesem kult ur modell es
ist ja so dass wie eine niederlage
die kultur des grenzenlosen wachstums
schafft ihre eigenen helden aktuell ist
viel von elon musk die rede der reichste
mensch der welt einer der autos baut für
eine zukunft in der es keine autos mehr
geben wird meint wälzer und elends fixe
idee den mars zu besiedeln ist so etwa
das gegenteil von aufhören das
interessante ist dass überhaupt nichts
neues drin das sind wirklich
60 70 jahre alter abgestandene utopien
und der einzige schaden denn das für
sich beanspruchen kann ist dass dann die
digitalisierung noch dazu gekommen ist
an diese ganzen geschichten der gemacht
werden immer auch noch gesa maßen binär
kodiert sind und dass flimmert noch ein
bisschen mehr und was geht daran ein
bisschen schneller es gibt bilder die
zustände auf den punkt bringen das
absurd große container schiff das im
letzten jahr den suezkanal verstopfte
die logistik des grenzenlosen konsums
geriet tage lang aus dem takt
welzer meint es braucht als
kulturtechnik das aufhören statt des
optimieren
klimakatastrophe artensterben braucht es
noch mehr die jahrzehntelange
kommunikation jedenfalls habe kaum etwas
bewirkt jede form von veränderung ist ja
immer auch erstmal eine zumutung
menschen sind ja nicht
veränderungsbereit besonders dann nicht
wenn es ihnen gut geht deshalb verfängt
diese kommunikation nicht weil es
niemals die die notwendige
transformation als etwas
herausforderndes als etwas attraktives
als ein projekt der besseren gestaltung
von lebenswelt
kommuniziert hat
und so hat wälzer sich auf die suche
gemacht nach menschen die wissen wie man
das aufhören am besten angeht
gefunden hat er reinhold messner der hat
ein drittel seiner expeditionen
abgebrochen weil sie zu gefährlich waren
oder undurchführbar
aufhören braucht einen grund aber
aufhören zu können braucht können sagt
messner
und da gibt es die geschichte von herrn
reckhaus einem fabrikanten von
insektenvernichtungsmittel er hat seine
berufung darin gefunden insekten nicht
nur zu töten sondern sie zu retten eine
neue art im kapitalismus zu wirtschaften
angestoßen durch die zusammenarbeit mit
dem schweizer künstler frank und patrik
riklin
[Musik]
überhaupt künstler maler
komponisten
sie können gesellschaftliche vorbilder
sein fürs aufhören
sie wissen dass ein wohl komponiertes
ende wichtig ist ein guter schluss das
ist das entscheidende
melzer selbst hat das nun konsequent
umgesetzt
ich würde es zum beispiel für meinen
persönlichen pfeil sagen dass ich nach
meinem letzten buch
mir gesagt hat das war es jetzt und zwar
aus dem einfachen grund es ist so eine
trilogie von büchern in den letzten
jahren entstanden zu einem themen
zusammenhang wo ich glaube ich würde nur
noch redundant werden wenn ich dann noch
ein buch schreiben das ist dann okay
also man hat dann das gesagt was man zu
sagen hatte und mehr ist nicht da dann
muss man die welt damit auch nicht
behelligen
[Musik]
die these gehört vom harald welzer wo
seit das wieder so schwer tut mit uwe
sind sie das abkommen nicht ich glaube
dass howie müsse das theater kommt jetzt
aber
müsse auch es ist ganz wieder fordert
und da er grote hatte das geld noch
runter das beruhigt
es ist
zeit einander haben wir noch mal zurück
zu dem bild das in indien entstanden
während ihrer
rekonvaleszenz innere klinik
wird noch der klassische therapie
finden ist
später wie
vor augen gifte und
aufbauen
und es ist sehr sehr aus lernen die zeit
es ist eine schwierige zeit die fast
zwei monate und
titanic
fotografiert ja das
material monate später abgeholt und in
einem zusammenhang
realisierten das aus in farbe und
das
schwarz-weiße
andern ist und das aus dass dann teilt
wahnsinnig kitschige weiß
vor beginn wollte und es ist
irrsinnig schönes
verarbeitet das vierte drittel und
poesie der angst weil rolle spielten
tanks beim fotografieren kreative
prozess also empfinde die angst also hat
er grosses schöpferisches potenzial
wenn man den mut die augen sturz war
es ja vielleicht sogar und sl mutig
arznei aus
rtl wo bleibt sind dass jetzt die letzte
bilder
wie vermutet also
notwendigkeit
bis neues machen dass brittany nicht
sagen aber es gibt ja noch ganz anders
aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
45 jahre lang zählte die zürcher galerie
ammann zur creme de la creme des
internationalen kunsthandels nur die
größten werk passiert sind die wände der
edlen zürcher kunst boutique nun aber
haben die aber aufgehört und zwar mit
einer letzten fulminanten auktion
670 millionen hört sich spannend im raum
den höhepunkt erreicht ein letzter blick
des auktionators sind in rom und das
marilyn monroe porträt von andy warhol
kommt inklusive der kommission für 195
millionen dollar unter den hammer
mit 195 millionen
und ein bisschen und 40.000 dollar
glaube ich bin ich sehr zufrieden mit
dem riesaer es ist natürlich es ist es
ist der höchste preis dass jemand
gezahlt hat für ein werk aus dem
zwanzigsten jahrhundert was eine
wunderschöne sache ist ich glaube dass
die marilyn das verdient sie sollte das
teuerste bild des zwanzigsten
jahrhundert seien die marilyn kommt von
hier einer bauhaus villa am hang des
modernen zürichberg
hier residiert die galerie thomas ammann
fine arts seit jahrzehnten gehen die
größen der kunstwelt in diesem haus ein
und aus
galerie direktor georg frey zeigt uns
das anwesen
letztes jahr ist galerie besitzerin
doris ammann die schwester des gründers
76 jährig gestorben und hat in ihrem
nachlass bestimmt die verbliebenen
kunstwerke zugunsten einer stiftung für
notleidende kinder zu versteigern
die kaumasse schauerartig sind ja auch
keine klinke hat die beiden seiten
schlossen beschaffung wir sind das kurz
team
und sind bei gmx zeit was für das kriegt
man im leben und alltag sieht das und
dass die dann und tätern und immer sind
sie mittelpunkt sie alle und ich glaube
dass ich irgendwas um die verharrt sich
aus dankbarkeit oder gar kein was sie
mit den la baracca hin mit ihrem
schicksal das sie dass man wieder gern
dass japan im winter bis kurz vor
die galeria mann war geprägt von ihm
thomas ammann erstiegen den 1980 er
jahren zu einem der größten
internationalen kunsthändler auf
handelte vor allem mit bildern der
klassischen moderne von picasso bis zur
wahl
der thurgauer mit viel charme eleganz
und einem potenten investor schaffte es
alle mit kunst zu bedienen von der
hollywood prominenz bis zur
industriellen familie war sie jogge
receiver oder im heimischen der
wertigkeit der data pack einfach auf das
ist jetzt die grosse verabreicht oder
verkauft oder die galerie ist ja nicht
so dass nur das ist der galerist
wohnfläche sie hätte den salons müssen
schnell um und hince bildern und etwas
früher hat er auch ein warhol
kennengelernt wo es durch ihn in der new
yorker kunstszene schnell aufgestiegen
es verband sie eine langjährige
freundschaft die auch von warhols umfeld
wahrgenommen würde
oder thomas langhoff
das ist de facto rehkitze krieg edward
und verschmiert aber der europäer der
elegante und clevere thomas ammann ist
auf geburt und der freundschaft gab es
am schluss bis zum 7 8 22
ammann wurde eine zentrale figur für den
handel mit warhol kunstwerken nur ein
bild hat er immer behalten die shops age
blue marin ersetzen ihr verkauften ihr
wegen der primar peter
habeler von dem glauben hieß das dass er
bis ganz wichtig ist und das ist er bis
die frau
lebe safari kam mit dem bild nicht und
jemand hat eigentlich gewusst dass das
durch
[Musik]
das bild ist 1964 in warhols factory
entstanden es ist eines von fünf
porträts von marilyn monroe die zwei
jahre davor gestorben war
dollar hat sie immer wieder gemalt doch
diese serie gilt als das meisterwerk
auch weil als die bilder fertig waren
eine befreundete performance künstlerin
auf besuch kam
vom ende also somit jetzt bezirk
schafften die hitzewelle die zähne
filmen avisiere sehr
extravagant und
die frau ein die maya shooter paintings
und ein die mannschaft hat ihr
fotografiert dass sie schon auf
fotografien oder fotografieren also
natürlich das handy wird grimm und die
sind hat die sucht aufgestellt sind in
der silber faktor ist
unternimmt die reform stößt ruf
warhol ist schockiert doch dann
restaurierte die vier bäder und eine
legende war geboren
der schuss später große das wird
ziemlich irritiert jeder mensch vor wenn
sie dann wenn sie john f kennedy danke
mit alaska schuss und das wiederholt
sich
dieses jahr für ein sexy unterschied
plötzlich ob in
2d angeschossenen marilyns landen beim
pop art sammlung leon kreischa für ein
paar tausend dollar dann folgen nur noch
sehr vermögende sammler ammann kräfte
sein bild in den 1980 er jahren vom
amerikanischen medien mogul es ein juhu
sogar anpfiff der oktober zeigte
sängers höflichkeit nicht
so viel aber dass ich doch
damals viel geld heute ein schnäppchen
man behält das bild bis zu seinem
überraschenden tod 1993 seine schwester
doris führt die galerie weiter und hat
die angeschossene marilyn bis heute
behalten
[Musik]
hatte
und ich bin
ja mehr nicht das kürzer das hätte
jetzt das
größere
macht ein wahnsinnig toll oder mit dank
da macht man es richtig ist es richtig
an sagt das so will auch jetzt dauert es
so
zerstört
[Musik]
auch wenn die trauerarbeit für georg
frey noch nicht vorüber ist mit dem
erlös aus dem verkauf der marilyn und
noch weiteren bildern wird er mit der
thomas und doris ammann stiftung wohl
vielen notleidenden kindern helfen kann
[Musik]
ziemlich genau 40 jahre ist es her dass
die sterbe organisation exit gegründet
wurde ein junger mann ohne geld und
einfluss machte damals die idee der
sterbehilfe in der schweiz salonfähig
lange bevor die politik das thema ernst
nahm das war damals eine sensation und
bis heute ist es erstaunlich dass die
schweiz in dieser debatte im kampf um
das recht zu sterben eine pionierrolle
spielt
es ist wie so oft in der geschichte ein
skandal der den weg ebnet für eine
historische gesellschafts politische
umwälzung an
einem frühen januarmorgen
1975 holen bewaffnete polizisten
professors harmonie aus dem weg der
vorwurf gegen den bekannten internisten
am zürcher triemli spital lautet
vorsätzliche tötung hermann hatte
hoffnungslosen fällen auf seiner station
nur noch wasser gegeben seine
vorübergehende verhaftung sorgt
international für schlagzeilen
dabei hat herr x ich das getan was
einige ärzte schon lange und im
einverständnis mit ihren patienten
praktizieren passive sterbehilfe
der rasante medizinische fortschritt des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts verleitete zu
allmachtsfantasien die ärzte waren die
neuen herren über leben und tod
beschreibt journalist karl lüönd damals
nachrichtenchef des blick das problem
war dass viele ärzte nicht
den tod eines patienten aus persönliche
professionelle niederlage
aufgefasst haben und das unter umständen
vermeiden wollten selbst um den preis
der vermehrten qualen für den
betroffenen patienten
die gesellschaft alarmiert durch die
zunehmende machtlosigkeit gegenüber dem
medizinischen apparat will mehr
mitspracherecht
bis hin zum selbstbestimmten tod
sagt karl
der 77 jährige hat im auftrag von exit
die geschichte der sterbehilfe in der
schweiz recherchiert und die wichtigsten
wegbereiter auf rund 300 seiten zu
papier gebracht
eine der schlüsselfiguren dabei ist der
damals 20 jährige kv lehrling rolf ihler
er hat in der zeitung über sterbehilfe
gelesen und beschlossen von seinen
möglichkeiten als aktiver gestalter der
direkten demokratie gebrauch zu machen
also soll eine volksinitiative her
sterbehilfe erfüllt für unheilbar krank
das war fett gedruckt das sehe ich doch
vor dem geistigen auge oder lila ist
wild entschlossen die notwendigen 5000
unterschriften für seine kantonale
initiative fristgerecht
zusammenzubringen dafür steht er täglich
nach feierabend auf der straße ich habe
gewusst ich habe 180 tage zeit und war
5000 und darum habe ich wirklich bei
jedem wind und wetter ich hab mir
september angefangen scout
so einfach es ist die unterschriften zu
sammeln so einfach kommt die kantonale
sterbehilfe initiative im herbst 1977 im
ersten anlauf durch
obwohl alle parteien mit ausnahme der
evangelischen volkspartei und der
kommunisten
das ganze nicht einmal bekämpft sondern
ignoriert haben
haben 58 prozent der stimmbürger des
kantons zürich damals schon diesem
anliegen zugestimmt
es ist quasi der zeugungsakt eines der
progressivsten sterbehilfe gesetze
weltweit auch weil die politik die
zeichen der zeit verschlafen und die
dringlichkeit des themas völlig
unterschätzt hat die konservativen
kreise sind außer sich die nz versteigt
sich gar zum titel panne der demokratie
doch das volk hat gesprochen
und auf betreiben der pensionierten
berner lehrerin hedwig zürcher gründen
sich die exit vereine in der
französischen und der deutschen schweiz
[Musik]
1985 wird die erste sogenannte
freitodbegleitung durchgeführt
zum einsatz kommt bei diesen
assistierten suiziden bis heute
natrium-pentobarbital
ein mittel das zum einschläfern von
tieren verwendet wird
liebe zuschauer in einem guten auge
es folgt eine zeit der intensiven
auseinandersetzung zwischen befürwortern
und gegnern vor allem die tatsache dass
der mensch das recht in anspruch nimmt
gott gegebenes leben zu beenden ist für
die katholische kirche nicht akzeptabel
problemlos sich sehr problem hafte der
mensch vor allem der langjährige
geschäftsführer der reformierte pfarrer
rolf sieg ist berühmt berüchtigt für
seine angriffslust
damit beschert er der sache zwar
regelmäßig schlagzeilen aber auch eine
zunehmend erbitterte gegnerschaft
selbst innerhalb der sterbehilfe
bewegung interner grabenkämpfe münden in
der abspaltung einer teilorganisation
und führen schließlich zur entmachtung
der galionsfigur sich
die wogen glätten soll eine junge frau
an die spitze von exit deutsche schweiz
wird die genferin elke petzner gewählt
mit diesem vorschlag habe ich nicht
gerechnet ich habe also keine
antrittsrede vorbereitet petzner soll
als erste frau den heillos zerstrittenen
verein befrieden
mit kompromissbereitschaft und
verhandlungsgeschick gelingt ihr schnell
der image wandel in der öffentlichkeit
diese organisation einen ein
ausdruck von seriosität und von anstand
und von ehrlichkeit zu geben und da
passt einfach nicht dazu dass diese
großen herren die großen namen und titel
dass die sich möglichst öffentlich
gestritten haben also deckel drauf der
neue führungsstil nach innen wie außen
bringt exit ab der jahrtausendwende
einen ungeahnten zulauf obwohl sie heute
nur eine von sechs
sterbehilfeorganisationen ist zählt sie
fast 150000 mitglieder und trotzdem
schadet nicht einmal ein prozent davon
am ende tatsächlich mit assistierten
suizid aus dem leben die meisten leute
wollen sich einen notausgang
bereithalten für alle fälle sie wissen
nicht was kommt
und das ist wahrscheinlich einfach ein
akt der vorsicht
auch die angst der gegner die schweiz
verkomme zur sterbetourismus destination
hat sich nicht bewahrheitet es gibt
kranke die zum sterben in die schweiz
reisen aber auch sie sind die ausnahme
nicht die regel
sterbehilfe made in switzerland hat eine
beachtenswerte entwicklung vollzogen sie
ist heute breit akzeptierte bestandteil
einer selbstbestimmten lebens und
sterbekultur und vom tabu zum viel
beachteten modell für europa geworden
dass immer mehr nachahmer findet
[Musik]
ja wir heute ist jetzt der richtige
zeitpunkt um aufzuhören zumindest mit
dieser sendung wir verabschieden uns aus
biel wo sie die fototage bis ende mai
besuchen können wir melden uns nächste
woche wieder und dann geht es bei uns um
die singles die immer zahlreicher werden
und hier auf sf1 sehen sie nun den
philosophischen stammtisch eine gute
woche für sie
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
street los
[Musik]